I'm obsessed of the video I saw on
Facebook recently it's a young girl who
got bullied for her hair and she wasn't
having it
take a look so yesterday I went to
school and I wore my hair in the afro
like this and a lot of people had a lot
of mean things to say about it so that
made me feel some type of way I told my
mom and she said promise don't forget
who you are and whose you are and said
okay so today I'm gonna go to school and
I'm gonna come back bigger and better
and don't allow anyone steal your joy
don't forgive them that much power she's
only ten years old but I want to make
her my life coach coz I love her promise
is here along with her mother Queen so
okay promise tell me what happened we
got to school so um when I went to
school I would Meyer an afro and a lot
of people had a lot of mean things to
say about it and that really surprised
me because at my other school everybody
used to love it like they was I promise
I love your hair
but when I went to this school everybody
just had like several negative things to
say about into yeah yeah that's mean
kids can be mean junior high sucked for
me um it wasn't fun but as moms we tried
so hard to protect our kids and I'm
gonna be real with you I probably would
have walked up to that school
I would I would not have handled that
well maybe lost a couple jobs I would
not handle that well because it's your
baby somebody's talking to your baby and
they don't even know your baby they're
just making fun of something that may be
different than what they they're used to
what did you tell her when that happened
so she came home and of course kind of
stressed what happened she's like I feel
that I'm feeling sad I'm feeling this
and she kind of gave me like a plethora
of emotions and immediately I wanted to
like defend and and I'm like no no no
promise I had to stop her we not having
a pity party and I had to tell her no
how did you feel this morning you know
how did you feel he walked out and she
said I felt confident I felt good I feel
great about I felt cute didn't she go
catch it but they said mean things and
they said this and then she's kept going
in I'm like no no no how do we feel
about it and she said I felt good and I
said that's all the matters I said
to create the video so we went kind of
like the end of that conversation where
I told her I said we're not going to
allow what someone says to dictate our
entire day you can give it a little
moment but not the entire day and so she
said okay and so when she said okay
it wasn't like us like okay I feel good
about kind of okay here's mom again but
the next morning I'm just brushing my
teeth and she's like where's your phone
I'm like okay so I came out for brushing
my teeth and just heard her like saying
those words and I was like but you just
you flipped it you turned it into a
positive you turn it into confidence I
love that how did the kids react to
anyway back the next day they're kind of
used to it but some people still were
asking like why are you wearing your
hair like that was like why are you
wearing your hair like that
I love that your video though has
inspired so many people including my
guest
my first guest well she is a Golden
Globe award-winning actress and the star
of blackish the last time I saw her she
was singing a moment like this at the
American Music Awards it was awesome say
hello to Tracy on this Rasta
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right here a little bit promise I saw
your video and I was so moved because
your hair is an extension of your legacy
what you come from your story and
everything that you are and your beauty
and I'm so glad that you knew at 10
years old what it took me so long to
learn about myself and you are such an
example well done on the parents you
promise she's actually the grown version
she's very honest on social media you
don't hide anything you're very proud of
like your body your hair where you come
from everything and I think that that's
a beautiful thing and it's such a
beautiful matte look how much you touch
people
your hair looks gorgeous today too
what do you do you want to say anything
to her all these women that stand up for
like who they are and they're real
they're not filtered all the time
they're just exactly in the raw how they
are like what do you want to say to
Tracy and all these women that do that
just keep doing what you're doing and
just go make the world a better place
well Tracy this wasn't even expected I'm
losing my mind it's fine anyway Tracy I
love this video of you as well we're
gonna roll the tape here
last night's pasta dinner dinner right
here lunch and this is God given so
great never knew but I loved that you
were like this is mine this is mine yeah
and this is lunch but why is it
important to you to be able to stand up
and be yourself why do you feel like
that's important you know this idea of I
woke up like this
I get 18 at 10 years old maybe I did but
I work for this body and this hair in
the space and all these things at 46
years old and I also really feel like
Instagram and and media and social media
can create this image of us this curated
image that people think is real we as
people as human beings are these full
beings that like have good moments and
bad moments bad hair moments good hair
moments and all these things and and I
feel like it's really helpful for me
when I see other people in their truth
it makes me feel comfortable with myself
yeah this gorge thank you it's gorgeous
it's beautiful it's hot it's sexy it's
all the adjectives thank you and it and
its essence I want it tomorrow that look
like that yeah this is what I just wear
to bed at night my husband dreams I did
my glasses I like to tuck my sleeping
t-shirt into my underwear and then the
pajama pants
I want anything to get in I don't like a
draft when I'm sleeping oh my gosh I'm
opposite but what does being on the
cover this mean to you because that's
essence it means a lot to me this is the
fourth time that I'm on this cover
actually but X's does such a beautiful
job and has for decades and years and
never ending of really representing our
community in such a beautiful way in all
of our diverse Beauty curly coily and
tight textured hair was not always a
part of the culture of beauty although
we for decades and eons have been
wearing our hair in its natural form
there is a revolution of celebration
happening right now as people begin to
understand the beauty that has existed
within us forever yeah I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this